I believe you're a big dork Mabel and
dipper pines we totally miss you in all
your adventures in gravity falls
we know you sometimes got into way too
much trouble and that life in gravity
falls was pretty crazy but you had fans
all over the world unfortunately some of
your shenanigans just didn't translate
well it turns out that you and your
friends could be a little offensive to
people in other countries but we know
you guys didn't do that on purpose
gravity falls was a hilarious show but
they were quite a few scenes that had to
be edited in other countries check out
these ten scenes that were changed for
international audiences well I do know
the lamby lamby dance what the heck in
English heck is considered a
kid-friendly exclamation but in other
countries it is still considered
inappropriate almost every example of
heck is cut in the Southeast Asian
version of gravity falls one example is
in the episode A Tale of Two Stan's
Mabel asks but the International Version
censors that word instead she just asked
what is going on at least the meaning
wasn't lost lost in translation okay we
know that Mabel is never afraid to speak
her mind and she isn't always the most
polite person when she's upset but
Disney Channel considered her lines
appropriate for kids at least in the US
but her very first major insult was not
okay for other countries in tourist
traps Mabel is understandably upset that
the gnomes expect her to marry them she
calls them all a certain mean name but
in other countries this insult was just
changed to you guys our faces the end of
Stan Pines we were shocked when we found
out the truth about Stan Pines who knew
that he had a twin brother trapped in
another dimension the episode not what
he seems revealed a lot of information
we can't forget how we felt when dipper
and Mabel found the newspaper the
headline said that
but this was changed in latinamerica the
headline instead read the end of Stan
Pines that sounds way more dramatic than
the English version no more violence
America shows tend to have a lot more
violence than other countries a lot of
places don't consider this very
family-friendly
one example of a violent scene being
censored in gravity falls comes from the
first season finale the episode Gideon
rises has Mabel and dipper trying to
save the mystery shack from Gideon
gleeful they recruit the gnomes to help
the gnomes attack Gideon's guards and
the guards collapse this scene was cut
from the Asian broadcasts dippers
awkward moment who doesn't ship dipper
and Wendy poor dipper had such a crush
on her for so long and he just wasn't
smooth at all in the episode into the
bunker he has a horrifying moment he
agrees with Wendy that all they'll ever
be his friends dude you're laying on my
bra I need freaks out but this scene
wasn't appropriate in other countries so
it was cut zombies are dumb okay we get
that insults aren't very nice and we
understand that it's less appropriate in
other countries but is it seriously not
okay to insult the zombies they're
monsters and zombies aren't that smart
dipper Mabel and Stan defeat the zombies
by singing in scary-oke Stan yelled but
several countries cut this word from the
scene can't believe they cut that line
keep watching to find out which entire
scene was cut and why gosh hand
huckleberry one of the funniest parts of
gravity falls is the way the characters
swear without saying real swear words
and bud gleeful is a character who says
some hilarious fake curse words in the
stanchion candidate bud unleashes a long
string of fake bad words but he includes
the word darn a couple of times in the
Southeast Asian broadcast of the show
darn was cut so he just says gosh hand
huckleberry honeysuckle girl problems
poor dipper in roadside attraction he
was just trying to learn how to talk to
girls instead he ends up with multiple
dates the girls are obviously upset but
then he really needs their help to save
Stan from Darlene he tells fans
in trouble you can totally kill me later
joking about murder doesn't translate
well to international audiences this
line was cut from other versions of the
show to make it more culturally
appropriate Greg in a graveyard
different cultures handle loss
differently and graveyards don't look
the same all over the world in America
you might expect to see lots of stone
crosses in a graveyard but since other
religions are more common in Asia you
wouldn't technically see this in the
final episode of gravity falls we see
Gregg Valentino pushing a zombie back
into the ground there's a stone cross at
the front of the shot this cross was
blurred out in the Asian broadcasts of
the show minigolf crime scene
vandalism is a crime pretty much
everywhere you go so in some countries a
scene from the Gulf War wasn't quite as
funny
Robbie Valentino spray paints the word
wieners at the mini-golf place this
could also be seen as inappropriate he
gets run off by the Mattress King we
can't see it but the Mattress King says
wow that's a lot of things in the scene
that aren't family-friendly the whole
scene was cut in other countries for
obvious reasons before you go tell us
who your favorite gravity falls
character is in the comments section
below thanks for watching don't forget
to like this video and subscribe to the
things we'll catch you next time
[Music]